how well do we understand facial
expressions emotional expressions are
much more nuanced and variable than
people have assumed and do our faces
reliably express our feelings
what's emotion is this person feeling
what about this one we can use facial
expressions to communicate how were
feeling and but it can also as or
reflect different personality trees is
this person distraught or related
furious or celebratory
[Music]
the interest in facial expressions and
the modern science emotion really began
in the 1960s with a scientist named
sylvan tompkins and two of his
postdoctoral fellows Paul Ekman and Cal
Izzard they were very interested in
testing the hypothesis that everyone
around the world
scowls when they're angry smiles when
they're happy and correspondingly that
everyone around the world recognizes
those facial movements as expressions of
emotion these ideas start largely
unchallenged for a generation but many
researchers now believe that the picture
is a lot more nuanced what we're dealing
with is highly variable highly context
sensitive temporarily changing patterns
and these contexts are one of the key
factors researchers are investigating as
they try to understand facial
expressions while people are moving
their faces they're also speaking their
acoustical changes in the vocalizations
there are body postures the person
carries around with them a whole
internal context of their body and then
there's the external context you know
who else is present what kind of
situation are they in what are they
doing and then there's a temporal
context and all of that contextual
information really matters
so whereas scientists used to focus
primarily on the face now they're
focusing more on faces in context
research into expressions as typically
relied on showing subjects posed
photographs
of faces representing different emotions
but photographs like this are often just
spaces in isolation with no context at
all also because they are static they
lack the temporal context which could be
read in a moving things
what's more the researchers have to
start by assigning emotions to
expressions which can introduce biases
and subjectivity to get around this
researchers are turning to technology to
find more neutral ways of studying
emotion the approach that we take is
more of a bottom-up objective approach
Rachael Jack's research uses a computer
which randomly generates dynamic facial
expressions we've used this really to
look at and mean differences between
cultures in terms of the six classic
emotions happy surprise fear disgust
anger and sad and we found that East
Asian and facial expressions of these
emotions tends to be signaled primarily
with the eye region so the eyebrows and
differences in the eyes whereas with
Westerners the feast movements tended to
vary more in the mouth region these
differences also and the location of
expressivity on the face is mirrored
very nicely in cultural emoticons
so in western emoticons what you find is
that there's two eyes and then the mouth
tends to be read to be able to express
sadness happiness and so on and it's the
opposite pattern with East Asian
emoticons in that the mouth is either
minimized or it's completely absent and
it's the variance of the eyes which
communicates different emotion messages
differences like this are leading some
researchers to believe the expressions
are not as universal as once thought and
that some behaviors might be learnt in
childhood what's happening in early
childhood is emotion knowledge is being
bootstrapped into the brain into the
brains wiring this is also what happens
when you change cultures when you move
from one culture to another culture you
have to learn what is a the nod of a
head or the where the raise of a lip or
the shake of a head you know
what are these things actually mean in
this culture despite these complexities
the idea that facial expressions could
be used as a way to read emotions has
excited big business leading tech
companies have already started
developing algorithms to detect
expressions and one estimate suggests
the industry could be worth fifty six
billion dollars by 2020 core systems are
already being trialed all marketed in a
wide variety of fields for hiring
purposes in educational settings in
security settings and in certain places
even in legal settings but despite the
predictions many scientists think the
claim software could mean emotion may be
premature we often make facial
expressions that can be an emotion
message but doesn't necessarily and mean
that we have this emotion inside so
oftentimes we smile out of politeness we
want to convey to the other person that
you know they're welcome etc but this
doesn't necessarily mean that you're
experiencing an emotion the other
challenge is that and it could be very
easy to trick automatic facial
expression detection systems so we may
want the system to believe that we are
feeling sad or happy and so it'd be
quite easy for a human then to to create
now to generate realistic facial
expressions that could trick a system
[Music]
you
[Music]